Think back to the beginning of this
lesson. Where we considered a computer system that
was displaying graphics for a video game.
Playing music or browsing the web. Seemingly all
of them at the same time. All of these applications need access to the physical
hardware And they have to be made to
share nicely. No hogging the CPU, no overwriting
each other's coder data. This becomes then the
job of the operating system, to protect these
applications from one another, and to protect an
application from itself. While getting out of the way
as quickly as possible so that these applications
can do what they need to do in order
to get their jobs done. Now we will
discuss the abstractions in an operating system. From managing
the hardware safely and efficiently. Particularly we'll
focus on the processor and the memory.